London and modern Utopia thanks to
exciting advances in Steam technology
even now steam Vehicles crowd London's
Fair streets Beyond capacity which is
why we are all looking forward to
today's event the grand opening of the
steam Gate Bridge our live broadcast of
the opening ceremony begins in just
minutes stay tuned the troops are in
position Captain
Roger that
ah
what a ship she's called The Lady
Liberty
Mr President the queen needs you
foreign
thank you
this is Henry I've got a contact
I see one
that did the trick
s for the help partner
thank you
now getting underway
good now fire the mega boilers to
maximum pressure and make speed for
Washington